i'm pleased to say that the shadow
education secretary bridget phillipson
is with us now uh bridget phillips and
good morning to you thanks for being
with us we'll pick up on some of that
toy inviting in a moment but first of
all where's kirsten uh well i think like
everyone kia stamber is entitled to a
holiday that's perfectly fine you'll be
hearing a lot more from us soon about
the additional support that we need to
put in place for families i mean we've
said an awful lot i mean we've been
consistently ahead of the government in
setting out the action that families
need right now you know the numbers are
terrifying but what i hear from people
about how worried they are about what's
coming you know we've been saying an
emergency budget was needed for months
we would cut vat on gas and electricity
bills we wouldn't have put up people's
taxes we wouldn't have cut universal
credit we would be planning for the long
term as well around our energy security
so you've heard a lot from labour but
you will hear more do you think that
message is cutting through though
because we've had gordon brown saying it
over the weekend you're telling me now i
spoke to alison mcgovern as well just
the other day but we're not hearing from
the leadership
we recognize that more is needed i think
we are entering a really serious and
difficult point of this crisis but this
cost of loan crisis i mean it's clearly
getting worse the numbers that we see
are really really concerning and i hear
from people all the time
pensioners who are worried about what
the winter holds parents who tell me
that are skipping on meals so their kids
don't go without i mean you know this is
britain in the 21st century and it is a
damning indictment of 12 years of
conservative government that we're in a
position where families are facing this
massive squeeze where more children are
in poverty and golden brown is
completely right
to highlight that i mean you know we saw
what he did from government we saw that
the action that labour took to lift
people out of poverty to provide
well-paid highly skilled jobs but the
government's failure over these last 12
years where it comes to renewable energy
and new nuclear that's meant that we are
uniquely exposed as a country we haven't
had that long-term planning if we'd had
that we'd be in a much much stronger
position as a country i mean you've seen
the reporting that we could be facing
blackouts this winter uh what's your
response to that and what would a labour
government be doing to try and make sure
that we didn't whatever blackouts well i
seriously hope it doesn't come to that
but i think it is shocking that after 12
years we haven't had the investment in
renewables in fact we sold this trust
yes just yesterday dismissing renewables
you know deriding that kind of
investment we haven't had the investment
we haven't had any nuclear we haven't
had insulation of homes 19 million
drafty homes right across our country if
we take an action to insulate those
homes and labour would take action right
now we would see 400 pounds off the
energy bills of families that's a
massive massive difference but also it's
a really important opportunity i think
for us to create well-paid highly
skilled jobs across our country we do
face that climate emergency we heard
just about the heatwave that we've got
coming as well but it's also an
opportunity to provide new great jobs in
places where you know that work is
desperately desperately needed and how
would it all be paid for i mean the
windfall texture managed to bounce them
into doing that it seems like they're
going to expand it today from the
discussions they're having um what about
ed davies idea of putting of not
bringing in the price capital well i
think you know we should look at
options that are there you know i i
would look seriously at any options that
will provide immediate support to
families but i tell you it's a bit hard
to take lectures from ed davey he was
secretary of state responsible for
energy and climate change in the
conservative lib dam government it was
his government's failure to plan for the
long term to deliver a new generation of
nuclear power stations to insulate our
homes that cut back on renewable energy
that has left us in this position right
now as a leader of parties out with the
big ideas your leaders on holiday no you
will be hearing a lot more i can tell
you we've been consistently ahead of the
curve since last autumn we were saying
we needed a windfall tax we've been
saying we need an emergency budget for
months i've been coming on programs like
this for a long time saying what was
needed we've set out lots of plans
whether it's extra help around breakfast
clubs extra support around child care
for our younger children not cutting
universal credit vat cut on gas and
electricity bills not going ahead with a
national insurance rise but we've got a
government completely absent a zombie
government you know a prime minister who
wants to hang around stick it out call
himself prime minister but not take the
difficult decisions that are needed and
the two contenders for the tory
leadership contest just taking lumps out
of each other when i speak to people who
tell me how on earth am i gonna get
through this winter how am i gonna pay
my bills labour would take that
seriously we would take action not just
taking cheap shots as the conservative
contenders are right now now you know
that comes so many constituents are
really worried as you rightly lay out
and some of them would have signed up to
this don't pay uk movement and it seems
to be growing all the time this is an
idea of not paying your bills come
october the 1st what's your advice to
those people who say they won't be
paying their bills well i think it's
terrible that we're in this position
where people are even considering that
but of course we all have responsibility
to pay our bills but i know for lots of
families that's going to be really
really tough we see the growing demand
at food banks including from people who
are in work food banks actually who tell
me that they're seeing reduced donations
because people can't even afford to
donate to food banks and where people
are turning down goods that require them
to cook them at home because they don't
have the money to cook the food that
they've been given from food banks so i
think it is shocking that we're in a
position now in modern britain where so
many children so many families and so
many pensioners are desperately worried
and we will see rising levels of poverty
across our country britain can and
should be a lot lot better than this but
we need a government on our side making
that happen now we've had the
announcement that we're going to see
strikes coming from raw male workers
nurses are going to be um
balloting to see whether they strike as
well in the coming months do the labour
party think that they will lose votes if
they fully get behind striking workers
well i i want to be the education
secretary in the next labour government
so i see my responsibility as not about
standing on picket lines but about
trying to find a way through all of this
and i think i understand completely the
pressures that workers are facing right
now i've heard from lots of royal mail
and bt workers for example in my
community who are really worried about
how they're going to pay all these bills
and want to see a decent pay settlement
from their employer i think that's why
it's absolutely vital that the employer
and the unions get around the table and
that the government makes sure that we
get those kinds of settlements in place
and where it comes to our public sector
workers you know take teachers for
example
over the last 12 years they've faced
massive real terms cuts in their pace so
i understand with the rising workload
and the pressures that they're facing
they want better i totally understand
that they'd like to see more support
from the labour party i think well
working people in our country will
always have the support of the labour
party that's what we're about we were a
party founded to represent the interests
of working people across our country but
it does mean taking responsible
decisions about making sure that people
get around the table and trying to find
a way through this okay bridget phillips
shadow education section really
appreciate talking to you thank you
thank you